hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the topics
concerning friendship that Marcus
Tullius Cicero addresses really on in
his work on friendship is the
relationship between what gets
translated in some of the text as
advantage also as usefulness or utility
and friendship itself and there's a long
back history to this that we should
reflect upon a bit
Aristotle very famously distinguished
three different kinds of friendship one
of which is genuine friendship and it's
friendship in terms of the good as such
or the the noble virtue you get to know
the person and value them for themselves
and then there's friendships of pleasure
and then there's friendships of utility
or usefulness to--some Pharaon in greek
utility toss in latin and so Cicero is
well aware of this set of distinctions
now friendships of utility are
friendships in the weakest sense they
break down quite easily because they're
based on the mutual usefulness of the
people to each other and within the
scope of that relationship they have the
elements of friendship for example
mutual goodwill so long as the
usefulness holds up so the usefulness
is the basis for the friendship not like
friendships where the basis is you
actually liking the person and admiring
them and thinking they're a good person
and wanting to share time and indeed
your life with them so we've got we've
got two different kinds of friendships
and Cicero is less willing than
Aristotle to call friendships of utility
friendships in any real sense they are
definitely relationships but they're
lacking in some of the the key elements
and so there's this long backstory
already philosophically and then there's
all sorts of discussions about real-life
friendships that people are having that
sometimes break down so we can say that
friendship definitely for Cicero is
something that is advantageous the
question is is the basis of an advantage
and Cicero thinks that the basis of it a
genuine friendship is not the
friendships advantageous Nisour
usefulness he does note that there are
quite a few people who do reduce
friendship to advantage or usefulness
and they assume that advantages as he
puts it the cement of friendship as a
matter of fact he frames it in a verbal
way saying that it's what holds that
friendship together nom see you Julie
toss conglutination
is right and then he says 'hey adam
camuto dis all Verret when when that's
gone when that usefulness is taken away
the friendship breaks apart it dissolves
and so you know in this case what we've
got is a double use of the advantageous
the advantage is what sparks the
friendship one person needs something
from another the other person needs
something from them and then they have
the friendship going on so long as what
they're getting what they need the
friendship per ders and once you take
that element away it's gone
Cicero thinks that this is a misguided
view of a friendship that shouldn't be
based on usefulness as a matter of fact
he spends a good bit of time explaining
why real friendship is actually
something that arise
out of nature but he has two other
considerations that are very important
as well that are connected with this
this notion of arising out of nature one
is that people who don't need things
from other people and I think he has in
mind his great friend
Scipio Laelius his friend here very
successful person in in life who who
didn't really need things from other
people but who was very friendly towards
them was helping them out he said well
what advantage is he getting from them
really no advantage she doesn't need
their praise he doesn't need their money
he doesn't need their political offices
he's God at all he just wants to do good
where good can be done and so if
friendship were only based on usefulness
nobody would do that sort of thing right
they would always say well what am I
going to get out of it you're not going
to get anything out of it you're going
to get the opportunity to be a friend
and that's a good thing the other thing
that we want to keep in mind is that for
Cicero there are certain key elements or
dimensions of any real friendship one of
them is affection felt towards the other
person the other is what he calls
goodwill been a volunteer and this is
something that again Aristotle
identified is at the core of real
friendship as well so we feel mutual
goodwill towards others and that's
really what provides the basis of the
friendship not the usefulness the
usefulness is something that comes out
of friendship and you know good
friendship ought to be useful in some
respects but it's not the basis of it
and it's not what holds the friendship
together if it's a genuine friendship
now all that said Cicero is is going to
say that the greatest advantages will be
realized from friendship right so what
are some of these greatest advantages he
actually says friendship offers
advantages almost beyond my power to
describe almost because he is going to
describe them of course
so he says in the first place how can
life be what any is calls the life worth
living if it does not repose on the
mutual goodwill a friend again we see
that been a volunteer goodwill is
absolutely central you can live a life
but how is it going to be the life worth
living
think of the good life without friends
mutual goodwill is part of what makes
life worth living
makes it a decent life and you can think
about the times when you've been
particularly lonely or isolated on your
own don't know anybody separated from
the people that you do know through you
know disagreements or things like that
and how it takes a lot of the joy and
luster out of one's life and I think
he's quite right there he says what is
sweeter than to have someone with whom
you may dare discuss anything as if you
were communing with yourself now that is
a really wonderful phrase there and it
captures something about friendship you
know you can you can have your
co-workers but there's sides of yourself
that you wouldn't reveal to them all
right
some people even don't reveal themselves
to their their lovers their romantic
interests they have their life over here
with them and then they have you know
their friends and their friends actually
know them better we make sitcoms and
movies about this sooner or later the
lover discovers that the friend actually
knows the person better and they feel
you know upset and jealous about this
and a lot of you know plot points and
Sue after that depending on on which
movie we're talking about but there's a
reason for that
genuine intimacy means being able to
share yourself with another person and
there is something provided yourself as
a good self there's something really
good about that even being able to bear
the parts that are bruised and broken
and scarred over and in need of healing
can be incredibly liberating as well so
that that's one side of that he also
says there's
another part in prosperity and in
adversity friends help us out so he says
how could your enjoyment in times of
prosperity be so great if you did not
have someone whose joy in them would be
equal to your own and it's not just a
matter of while you discovered you know
a mountain of candy bars so you need
somebody else to eat through that
mountain with you know it's I mean even
if they're not enjoying the candy bars
let's say that they hate chocolate but
they find out that you've discovered
this mountain of candy bars and it's a
your favorite kind right and imagine
that you won't get sick of it after
eating you know I don't know a case of
them or it's nothing like that which is
probably not not really what would
happen they delight in your doing well
and so in prosperity your friends can
share in that prosperity in important
ways it augments your own happiness you
might say a little bit further down he
he also talks about that as well
he says friendship adds a brighter
radiance to prosperity
it says Splenda you're a socket to meet
a Makita
right so there's that and then what
about when you're not doing well what
about in adversity when things have gone
off the rails well we need friends in
those times as well and he says here we
go
adversity would be hard to bear without
him to whom the burden would be heavier
even than to yourself and a little bit
further down he says that the way in
which friendship lessens the birder
burden of adversity is by dividing and
sharing it so you know friends come and
console us they may in fact be able to
help us out in some degree but sometimes
they they can just be there for us and
that is part of what makes life good
that's one of the advantages of
friendship going out a little bit
further he he talks about friendship
projecting hope
space in Latin into the future that it
allows us to exhibit a kind of
orientation towards what is to come that
we wouldn't have if we were entirely on
our own so that's another advantage and
then he says something that's become by
his time it's sort of commonplace again
Aristotle is is one of the people who
talks about this earlier than Cicero
that the friend is in in a certain way
here he says a kind of image an exemplar
of oneself in other places in this text
a little bit later on he will bring up
the proverb that a friend is another
self and that we we sometimes think of
ourselves as you know two souls or one
soul and two bodies that there's a
connection between us right we talk
about soulmates or things like that and
now this is only possible within a
genuine friendship it's not going to be
something that happens through the
contingencies of just hooking up with
somebody or meeting somebody in a bar
being a classmate or a neighbor although
you know it could blossom and develop
into that if you're both good people but
this he thinks is something that is is
quite valuable for us human beings he
says that whoever looks upon a true
friend looks on this image of himself
and we could think about well why why
does that matter it's not a narcissistic
thing and narcissus of course was the
the youth who died by looking at his
beautiful image in the pool and
forgetting to eat because of that
instead it's a being able to discover
things about yourself you notice that
that later in the book sister will also
say friends have to hold each other to
standards and so that other self could
be the one who says to you man you're
screwing up you need to fix this part of
yourself and then finally one of the
other great advantages of friendship
that Cicero talks about that is very
interesting here is the capacity for
friends to remain present to
to remain you could say active in our
lives even when they are not there and
he gives up several different modalities
of this he says friends though absent
are at hand though in need yet abound
though weak are strong and harder seeing
still though dead are yet alive even the
friends that we've lost are in a certain
way with us why he says the wreck that
we have the tender recollection and the
deep longing that still attends them
says these things make the death of the
departed seem fortunate and the life of
the survivors worthy of praise and so
you know we're able to hold on to
relationships of people who have passed
out of our life for one reason or
another but towards him we had this
mutual goodwill and we can keep that
alive even past the physical death of
those people or the separation so these
are in his view many of the advantages
of friendship I actually skipped over
one here that I need to come back to he
says that friendship contains many
things and this is an interesting
passage here what does he mean by that
so he says that if we consider the goods
that people want some prefer riches some
prefer you know good health all of these
these sorts of things right but those
are good for one type of thing he says
that most other objects of desire are
adapted to a single end for the most
part riches money for spending right I
mean you can't eat the money you can buy
something to eat with it
that's what wealth is good for influence
for getting honor public office for
reputation you could say maybe that's
the wrong idea of public office right
but he's talking about what most people
think about here pleasures sensual
enjoyment health freedom from pain and
full use of your bodily functions and
then he says but friendship embraces and
the word here is
Genet right so it extends to it contains
it includes multiple things race Pluto
Remus he says turn wherever you are it
is ever at your side no barrier shuts it
out
it is never untimely and never in the
way so friendship in a way is a good
that is unlike other Goods and so that
makes it yet more advantageous than
these other Goods entertaining what it
is that we genuinely desire so these are
all major advantages of friendship that
derived from having a good friendship
they're not the basis of friendship they
are the fortunate result you might say
and they they probably do play a kind of
cementing role but without the goodwill
the beneful antia that has to be there
they're not going to last very long and
you probably won't actually attain these
add these advantageous conditions and
things
you